hello there
reject nation I'm Greg Alba John
Humphrey we're gonna watch and aldo
jones weird trailer his funny spoof
parody of the superbowl one I gotta tell
you guys I've seen that Super Bowl spot
way too many times today you're an
addict you need to stop no John that's
what addicts do they don't stop then you
get great movies like a star is born
so addicts keep being addicted don't be
a quitter aldo jones send us an email
saying hello for a guy who makes such
weird videos he's so professional hello
my new weird trailer was released and as
always i'd like to see your reaction
really tiny smiley face the link is here
isn't surly aldo jones he's gonna give
us a copyright strike afterwards this
one he does before we go into that I
just wanted to say although aldo jones
on youtube and also check out his
patreon page guys who puts a lot of hard
work in these videos he could use the
support and i imagine he deals with a
lot of copyright issues cochon the love
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
that's great sir
[Applause]
[Music]
but it points out is shaking fingers
good you know in a lot of ways I really
like is is even shorter ones yeah versus
see my long ones out I think the shorter
ones are just a bit okay oh wow that's
how he got himself in the video hangman
damn everyone's got to go to patreon
Wow oh my god how do I wear czaka saw
his name his name is usually here
raucous aww look at all these p.m.
studios we should start messaging these
people directly and being like hey if
you like out on Jones's patreon you
should come be in our patreon yeah
you'll not the same at all no if you all
get your name in a video necessarily but
you'll be on a patreon okay I like the
song because his outro music beautiful
it's got good techno person aldo one of
these days I'm gonna get back to you and
say you failed this was awful one of
these days I'll say that to you
don't worry and it's gonna be in the one
where your email us saying guys you
gotta do a reaction to this one because
this is my favorite one if you never
react to another one of my videos this
is the one I want and that's the one
where I'm gonna tear you a new one
[ __ ] you out Oh Jones yeah [ __ ] you and
go [ __ ] yourself yeah in the beginning
it was like okay he's done it again yeah
the Angry Birds image it's like
something I did not expect to see
happening and that's always part of the
fun is what randos are gonna find it
their way brando with the Aldo Rando
alder for she's a little dancing Toby's
at the table love them always the man I
think that was just a great like a
really witty joke that was really funny
with her where do we go now that they're
gone I know there was like a little bit
additional joke there where you caught
the age and the where I was in the
trailer and he's never done half of
people spelling went away to in the ages
go but now that was a funny ass joke
because of all that stuff with Henry
Cavill being on and then Ben Affleck
leaving means such an uproar and have
images and I just think that was a
really smart joke so and then like
breezing over this trailer just as I'm
scrolling through it I didn't even know
this tiny storage space inside yeah yeah
funny thing about your videos dude a lot
of times I just don't notice I don't
notice I don't even know Stanley older
white gentleman with the moustache it
took me a while to put that together
yeah I don't like that Stan Lee cameo I
mean kind of silly but also you know it
seemed nice to have him up in the sky
all big like like Mufasa what if that
was the cameo they shot I would love it
what if they just pret prepared so far
in advance for afterlife Stan Lee cameo
no that's the thing they probably did
and this is how they fixed the end game
as Stanley actually opens up the heavens
and is like I'm fixing spider and all
the characters who have time on their
consciousness and that's how we get all
the Avengers that would actually be
pretty cool plus I mean out do Deadpool
with a fourth-wall break just have the
creator of all the Marvel comics come in
and be like John and it all you're
smarter than people give you credit
everyone always says Greg's the smart
one yeah jon is the unintelligible one
so it's just pretty funny to me how like
people don't give you enough credit for
how you're smart once a year I got to
throw in a smart comment and this was it
this was it yeah well you're halfway
there I didn't realize how much I liked
Stifler or the like Lion King one you
had the Stifler moment where the game
peed on your insert a whole scene in the
more recent ones he's been doing that
more just inserting like any opportunity
to take a reverse shot and turn it into
like an intrusion
another movies uncomfortable moment yeah
and you know rocket seems like the one
who would come in on Stiffler the
problem is then I wanted to see him and
Stifler interact that's not a problem
not well I mean it's just your fan
theory I know you can go pitch it I
don't want to imagine it I just want to
see it with all the effort taking it
yeah although to work hard exactly
it'll be your least viewed video this is
me great artist working that's how
that's how many things are Jose man the
one that you put the most heart and soul
into is one of our rooms like now
whatever but this this thing you spent
no time on though that's their sketches
we've done they're taking weeks to put
together that people love but are easily
one of our lowest viewed videos of those
the memo moment I was wondering is that
an insert from something I've never seen
before or don't recall or did aldo draw
that or do you have like a child who's
great at drawing is that a live like
original shot did he actually shoot that
did he do it himself he could have just
drawn it but I think what he did was do
look like child plays yeah he probably
spliced it together from several other
source materials I want there to be a
whole scene and end game where people
are like why didn't you go for the head
thought them not like have it talked
about there you go yeah I'm sorry but it
wouldn't have been that hard it's the
big purple thing on top of it yeah yeah
it's actually easier to hit then the
center of his his armors gold the
contract they're complementary colors
man there's it's easy I want Bruce
Banner to pull down an Anatomy sheet be
like really it's the bridge the brain
everything else goes they haven't still
lived with if you had hit the heart but
if the brains function yeah have you
seen a zombie movie Thor I mean he's not
undead but it's the same Peugeot for
that I want to really compliment him on
his attention to detail that shot with
Ronan that famous shot was looking up
any it's it's all red love when the
genius are you here Will Smith's voice
in the blue and it turns to blue that's
some awesome attention yeah yeah I
really appreciated that too and that was
a nice like I should have been expecting
it to happen but I just wasn't so it
tickled me that much more yeah II with
that transition of like the blue light
washing over his face going
we're good at taking recent internet
controversial things in the
entertainment industry and infusing it
to create more weird and meta humor me
more videos you're good you're a meme
Lord oh no I want that I hope in the
next one you include something with
Bradley Cooper and Lady Gaga singing to
each other of the Oscars far from the
shallow now which I want to say what's
funny about that because I rewatched a
star is born last night oh good
yeah really short experience oh yeah
it's funny about this movie when they
sing shallow for the first time it
creates this whole thing where she's
going viral on the internet and people
want to know who she is and what the
relationship is and then they do that at
the Oscars or they sing shallow the
Cooper Lady Gaga and everyone starts
going what's going on with them with the
same song which is pretty neat so yeah I
include that in the next one that's my
more shallow B Block in the circulation
so this is all at his fingertips and
that's it funny enough that moment of
Captain America's handshaking is like
one of the most pointed out things in
the comments at least for our reaction
to either of those trailers
so you know I'm glad I took the
opportunity to appease those fans and
make it a bit was it's the the new
equivalent to when he's holding a nose
and yeah it's it's like oh [ __ ] is he
gonna die in this moment but instead of
gritting his teeth now his his hand is
shaking yeah well looks like he's on the
verge of losing hand is always steady in
hand steady mmm I was that's another
that's like it was a really smart moment
really such a smart comedy right there
man you surprised that no ant-man movie
has ever had a bit where he like
accidentally gets huge like after the
fact after he's done all the figuring it
out [ __ ] with all the you know sexual
assault controversy and stuff you don't
want to accidentally get huge in a
situation that's not warranted Jon I
don't know what I was thinking when I
made
because you are absolutely right I don't
know why brothers do not make light of
hub sorry don't make light of I'm gonna
make this listen before we wrap this
video up I would like to give a page in
the day shout-out to a man named Curt
Anderson Curt is actually 50 but he
looks 49 a great silver fox indeed and
he is one of our top reward to your
patrons wear whatever video your
question was definitely doing put up on
YouTube now he just likes having that
reward here
he didn't even request a video last
month it's like nope I just like having
the option and to everyone who's in that
top reward tier you can learn a thing or
two from Curt it's about the power it's
about the power in fact if you don't
request anything but you stay pledged
like Curt yes that makes us even happier
okay because uh who likes doing videos
you know who likes actually filming and
editing and doing that kind of work it's
much more time efficient just to make
the money and not do the work or
anything
Kurt you've taught me something you
taught me something special I don't want
to work and er say thanks so I hope when
you see this shout out that you increase
your pledge that just gets us closer to
our ultimate goal thank you buddy
you're really sweet you're very kind and
you bring out a lot of motivation to me
to be lazier than I already am so thank
you guys you can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
check out a little Jones who's going to
continue working